vamos a nuestra revista de prensa con
Marta mulla Marta Buen día para usted
Hola Ángela muy buenos días Vamos a dar
inicio a esta sección de directo América
con los medios hondureños que reportan
por supuesto en sus portadas sobre la
masacre de ayer en un penal en el
municipio de Tamara la noticia es de al
menos 41 reclusas muertas vamos a
empezar con la prensa y la tribuna si
Ángela vamos a empezar como decías con
la prensa en lo que se supone fue una
reyerta entre pandilleras de la Mara
Salvatrucha y el barrio 18 que no solo
operan en El Salvador también en
Honduras sigue como decías no acabó con
un saldo de al menos 41 víctimas
mortales todo ocurrió el app
penitenciaría nacional femenina de
adaptación social en el municipio de
Tamara cerca a Tegucigalpa la capital
hondureña y en este artículo de la
prensa se recogen algunos de los
entresijos de todo este episodio
mortífero todo empezó alrededor de las
7:40 de la mañana hora local cuando
comenzaron unos disturbios donde
presuntamente las pandilleras de la Mara
Salvatrucha increparon a pandilleras del
barrio 18 estas dos facciones
pandilleras viven en módulos separados
pero las escasas condiciones de
seguridad del penal pues permitieron que
después la reclusas del barrio 18
entraran al módulo de las pandilleras de
la Mara Salvatrucha y con gas
rociaranga sobre los colchones del
módulo 1 y al final todo se generará una
gran incendio según los relatos de la
supervivientes dado el hacinamiento todo
hecho arder muy rápidamente textualmente
La Prensa dice un grupo intentó salvarse
dentro de un baño pero quedaron
calcinadas y sus cuerpos unos encima de
otros después las pandilleras
presuntamente del barrio de 18
irrumpieron con armas y con fusiles en
otro módulo y en el patio del penal otro
audio recogido por una de las
supervivientes y recogido en la prensa
hay cuerpos en los pasillos en el patio
y unas quisieron huir por las paredes
pero les dispararon y hasta con piedras
enormes detuvieron su salida bueno los
familiares se enteraron por las propias
reclusas de que tenían que comparecer
ante las puertas del penal para saber si
sus hijas sus amigas sus parejas estaban
entre el balance de los fallecidos Por
otra parte La Tribuna dice que este es
un episodio más de la falta de seguridad
de los Derechos Humanos que hay en
Honduras sobre todo con la población
recluida citada por el medio La
comisionada Nacional de Derechos Humanos
Blanca izaguirre dice que Honduras
vulnera sistemáticamente los tratados y
los convenios internacionales respecto a
las garantías fundamentales y de
dignidad de la población recluida en las
cárceles desde el año 2003 1050 personas
han muerto en condiciones de violencia
en las cárceles hondureñas un tema por
el que el propio estado hondureño ya fue
bueno
por la Corte Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos en el año 2012 por otro lado
Ángela hemos destacado El Heraldo que
hace una fotogalería de algunos de los
momentos más críticos del suceso de ayer
en támara todo empezó con el traslado de
la reclusas a centros hospitalarios
Cuando entonces la opinión pública ni
siquiera sabía la dimensión de lo que
había ocurrido dentro del penal también
vídeos en redes sociales advirtiendo de
ese gran incendio en la cárcel eran el
preámbulo de lo que ocurrió después
imágenes que por supuesto fueron
blureadas de los cuerpos por el suelo de
la destrucción de la angustia de
familiares y también el dispositivo
policial que Se generó pero es que
martes es impresionante el nivel de
violencia es que yo no sé si algo así
pasaría en la calle y es la gran
contradicción de que suceda dentro de un
penal Sí donde la seguridad parece
máxima pero pues no lo es pero bueno de
todo esto Marta Yo rescataría mucho la
posibilidad de narrar pues estos
horrores porque Generalmente nos
enteramos no solo en este país sino en
no tienen tantos muertos y hasta luego Y
pues el dolor queda simplemente para las
víctimas absolutamente Ángela bueno
Marta vamos a seguir con más noticias
pero vamos a continuar en Centroamérica
el periódico salvadoreño el faro empezó
esta semana a publicar una serie de los
supervivientes que fueron encarcelados
bajo el régimen de excepción de nayib
bukele Y luego el liberados por falta de
pruebas esto es súper interesante y Abre
más el debate con esta guerra contra las
pandillas tan popular pero también tan
cuestionable en derechos humanos Pues sí
Ángela han pasado 14 meses y 25 días
desde que el gobierno de nayib bukele
impulsara este régimen de excepción que
ya hace tiempo Dejó de ser excepcional
el faro Pues un medio bien crítico con
el gobierno de nayib bukele empieza esta
serie en la que bueno gente que fue
detenida bajo el régimen de excepción
sin pruebas y luego fue liberada ahora
cuenta como vivieron ese tiempo en la
prisión esta semana han sacado el primer
testimonio y aseguran que tienen pruebas
y evidencias de que todo lo que cuentan
estas personas recluidas Pues es verdad
el primer relato es del profesor
Alexander Guzmán un subdirector de
escuela y que además manejaba una
empresa de taxis fue detenido el primer
día del régimen de sección a finales de
marzo del año pasado y fue trasladado al
penal de izalco fue víctima de palizas y
además vio como una agresión contra uno
de sus compañeros por parte de las
fuerzas de seguridad terminó con su vida
unos días después El Faro de manera muy
gráfica además ponen de relieve las
vulneraciones de Derechos Humanos que
sufrió esta persona en rojo las que
sufrió en verde las que no sufrió por
ejemplo pues eh Guzmán no sufrió abusos
sexual ni sufrió mutilaciones pero sí
sufrió la incomunicación con su abogado
sufrió tortura física psicológica y
además presenció asesinatos Ángela
precisamente nos ha rescatado usted
varios audios de la entrevista con el
profesor Guzmán que retratan muy bien
todo esto nos está contando sí Ángela
hemos destacado dos audios en el primero
Guzmán cuenta un poco Cómo vivió sus
primeros días en el penal las
condiciones de hacinamiento que sufrían
y también como exponían como trofeos los
policías a cada recluso que entraba en
las cárceles escuchemos
estábamos asignados estoy dormida
entrelazado parado amontonado uno con
otro
en ese momento el régimen se puso de
unas en una situación bien difícil donde
estaban llevando masas de gente montones
de gente capturada los policías salían
comisiones de ir a traer de día a 15
personas por viaje y llegaban y decían
misión cumplida este 20 misión cumplida
desde 15 o bueno desposado lo someten
como un delincuente lo ponen hincado en
el sol
en este segundo audio que vamos a
escuchar Alexander Guzmán relata un poco
las secuelas que le dejaron las palizas
que sufrió por parte de las fuerzas de
seguridad
escuchemos también este audio
estuvimos agonizando cuatro días con
tremenda fiebres tremendo fríos nuestros
cuerpos temblaban
y ahí pues algunos muchachos
algunos muchachos
este
de la poca agua sucia que había al fondo
de una pila vieja en la en la celda va
como podían con sus manos llegaban y nos
flotaban a lo que estábamos delirando de
la fiebre y todo y nos ponían agua en la
frente en el cuerpo sobre situaciones
tan complejas como esta Más allá de
calificar es bueno que la ciudadanía
tenga las herramientas para informarse y
tomar sus propias decisiones gracias a
usted Marta Porque además estos
reportajes de largo aliento son cada vez
más difíciles y más costosos para las
redacciones la invitación es a que la
gente pueda leer y escuchar y ver todas
estas imágenes que nos presenta el faro
Sí el reportaje está disponible en
Spotify Así que animamos a toda la
audiencia a que escuche porque los
relatos son impresionantes pues mire
Muchísimas gracias Marta nos vemos
mañana espero que con mejores noticias
que hoy gracias Ángela esta